es geht um ein missglücktes state kann
man nicht sagen dass endet letztendlich
mit mit einem gv mit einem
geschlechtsverkehr kathpress
es ist ja die geschichte die vor
eineinhalb jahren total viral ging wie
du weißt was ist mein englisch sehr
begrenzt und ich bin froh dass es jetzt
auf deutsch erschienen ist ich finde das
eine großartige geschichte
es geht um ein missglücktes tate kann
man nicht sagen sie lernen sich kennen
sie schreiben sich textnachrichten wenn
man sie mal mit langen ich finde ein
weiterer kunstgriffen so willst ist dass
sie sich aber im richtigen leben also in
real life eol wie man heutzutage sagt
kennenlernen und denkt sich also wenn
ich jetzt auf einer party gewesen wäre
hätte ich den kerl nicht angesprochen
aber jetzt wo er so von mir die nummer
will dann gebe ich sie ihm halt dann
kommt es zum ersten date sie schon so
leicht angesäuselt und sagt wollen wir
nicht zu dir und er sagt wer du bist ja
schon ein bisschen betrunken und dann
sagt sie stimmten stimmt nicht und dann
landen sie aber bei ihm und schlafen
miteinander und in dem moment wo er sich
auszieht denkt sich so richtig cool
finde ich den aber nicht aber wenn ich
jetzt sage nähe dann ist es wie wenn ich
im bestelltes essen zurückgehen lassen
das kann ich jetzt nicht machen das war
ja glaube ich auch der moment der dafür
ursächlich war dass diese geschichte so
viral gegangen ist in zeiten von me to
dass ganz viele frauen gesagt haben ja
ja das kennen wir und dann ist sie auch
nicht in der lage ihm zu sagen dass sie
ihn eigentlich nicht wiedersehen will
das muss eine freundin von ihr schreiben
weil sie das nicht schafft er akzeptiert
dass zuerst hat als sie ihm dann sagt du
ich will wirklich nichts mit dir zu tun
haben schreibt er ihr das letzte wort
[ __ ] [ __ ] auf deutschlandtour hier
in der übersetzung als [ __ ] hier in
der übersetzung als [ __ ] der
kunstgriff für meine begriffe dabei
nikola ist dass man zwar diese marco
begleitet aber trotzdem sie auch
kritisiert wird in der geschichte durch
das was sie tut man begleitet sie und
man merkt eigentlich ist es für sie
total wichtig was der für ein auto hat
das ist ja das schöne dass man irgendwie
von der sympathie der figuren immer
wechselt zwischen der identifikation mit
dem man unter identifikation mit der
frau gegen die das nicht so doch er ich
weiß nicht wie es euch geht habt ihr den
text gelesen
ich fand es ganz erstaunlich wie man
hin- und hergerissen wird von diesen
beiden positionen aber mich würde dann
schon interessieren seid ihr mehr auf
marx oder freibad seite oder seid ihr
wie ich sozusagen so ambivalent zwischen
beiden charakteren hin und her geworfen
[Musik]